From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I want to make a hand over the roll.
Okay. Today is Thursday September 15, 2011. My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with the videographer John Bishop and we are in Albany, Georgia to do an interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
And we're delighted today to be with Mr. Shirley Miller Sherrod here in Albany to talk about some Civil Rights History.
Thank you very much for the welcome and allowing us to visit.
Thank you.
I thought I'd start with just a question about that.
Okay, we just had a quick break for adjusting microphones.
Let me just ask you a little bit about coming up in Baker County and your family and your parents.
Well, as you know, grew up in Baker County, Georgia.
I grew up in an area where the family, our family, my grandmother's family had located some time either before or after the Civil War, but I picked them up in the county in the Census Report for 1870.
And at that time, they were a sharecropping.
They eventually, and I'm sure that was their purpose, started buying land.
And they worked together as a family to do that.
So my grandmother had about 12 or 13 sisters and brothers.
And she ended up having actually 14 children.
So the area she, her maiden name was Hawkins.
And they actually called the area that I grew up in Hawkins-family settlement.
And as I said, we were farmers, my grandmother and her husband, Julius Miller, were given, I think it was 31 acres by her father.
And they farmed and continued to buy more land so that by the time they passed on, they were able to give each of their children a minimum of 31 acres each.
So growing up around family, working on the farm, that was the early life in Hawkins-family settlement.
And of course, we lived in a county, Baker County had a particularly bad reputation in the area.
Now, we learned later on during the Civil Rights Movement that each sheriff tried to make people in the county feel that it was worse somewhere else.
But I think Baker County probably stood out even more than the others because of the sheriffs that we had in the area.
So during my lifetime it was L. Warren "Gator" Johnson, who was known as the Gator.
And the Gator had something to say and something to do with everything that happened in Baker County.
And he had the county so tight he had a speed trap set up where you just couldn't ride through without being stopped on road.
And if you were white, you knew you had to pay. If you were black, you had to pay, but you could also lose your life in the process.
So growing up in that in a very, very segregated atmosphere was my early life, you know, going to a segregated school.
In fact, the building we had when I first started school in the first grade, they were army barracks that had been placed there facing each other with a porch between them.
And during the, I think I went to the army barracks to fourth grade and then we had to get out into churches to go to school because they were finally building a new building for us in the county.
And it was Georgia's answer to separate but equal of what the integration they were built and supposedly separate but equal facility.
While that work was going on, some of us had to go to school. So I spent part of my fourth grade and fifth grade in one of the Methodist churches there in the county and family.
In April of 57, we moved into the new building.
Yes, I have four sisters and one brother. And the brother, of course, is the youngest.
And where did you come from, the second?
I'm the oldest of the group. There were five girls growing up and you know any man, I guess, a special farmer wanted a son and during those years of growing up, my father gave all of us boys nickname.
I was Bill, you know, so we'd be around on the farm working and he's, you know, Bill and he and my mother would have another child and it's another girl.
And finally during my senior year of high school, my mother kept getting sick. I didn't know what was wrong.
At school, when they, my best friend at she said, how's your mom? I said, she doesn't seem to be getting any better. She said, girl, your dad was at the store yesterday giving out cigars. Your mom was going to have a baby.
Yeah, convinced my mother to try one more time, just one more time for the son. And of course, he didn't live to see him. He was born two months after he was murdered.
Your family was involved in the church?
Oh yes, yes. That, you know, the church doors didn't open unless we were there. So we were there for everything that happened there.
And the church and that church was made up of most of those people who lived in Hawkins-family settlement. They were few who didn't live in that area.
The other part of the church was my mother's family who lived in another part of the county but was mostly family.
Did the fact that your family owned property? Did that distinguish your family in any ways that are important to comment upon in relation to other parts of the county?
Yes, because there were lots of plantations in Baker County, big plantations. One of them was Ichauway Plantation Plantation owned by Robert Woodruff of Coca-Cola.
Another one was Pineland Plantation owned by the Mellon family out of Pennsylvania.
You could tell the kids who lived on a farm that was owned by the family and I need to sneeze. I'm sorry.
My sonuses have been acting up today.
So you could really tell the difference between the kids who lived on land that was owned by the family versus those who lived on land that's owned by plantation owners or others, especially during harvesting time and even during some planting seasons.
Because the kids who lived on plantations had to work on the farm. For example, we used to hate it.
There was a time when planting cucumbers, there was a buying point put up in Baker County and it gave the land owners an opportunity to have some income at a critical time which was in May and June for the farm.
So of course all of the land owners were planting lots of cucumbers.
So you could tell the kids who lived on land owned by the family because every other day Monday, Wednesday Friday at noon our parents would be there to pick us up during cucumber season because you had to go home and pick cucumbers.
It was so hard to get the stain off your hand but you know that was the difference and you know looking back it was we hated it.
But looking back it was something to really be proud of because we worked hard of course on the farm and it was a way of also being able to have some of the things that we wanted like clothes, new clothes for school and all.
But there was a special feeling even back then from knowing that you were doing something on land that you are your family owned.
Do you remember the proximate racial composition count?
Of Baker County during those days it was about 60% black.
Do you have a, when you think back are there specific recollections around race relations say that might be related to the, you born in 48 so brown would have been about 47.
You would have been a young child still at the time of brown if before but I'm thinking about Montgomery or were there moments when that question became something that played more on your mind as a child?
Of course I can remember well we had the worst buses.
We had the hand me down books from the white school system so you were you know you open a textbook and sometimes writing would be in and pages torn out and you knew those things were coming over.
From the white school and there were many times when the buses we were writing in would be so much in need of repair that they were break down and even that can remember sometimes very vividly.
The bus being on fire the fire under the hood of the bus and someone hollow and fire and you know people are crawling out of windows and out the back door and the front door and the older guys you know would raise the hood and throw sand under.
And you know they are on the fire to put it out that happened many many many many times as we were in school and one thing sticks out in my mind during those days the visit and teacher was the wife of the superintendent.
And she just she walked into and I was a junior or senior in high school I can't remember I know at least a junior in high school and she walked into this class it was a French class and just made the teacher feel like she was nothing and just took over the classroom and started writing words on the bus I mean on the board for us to pronounce.
You know it was just I just remember feeling so bad for the teacher let alone us but for the teacher the way she just came in and made her feel like she was nothing and then made us say those words until we said them with that southern twang that she used and remember government was one of the words that she put on the board and I can remember thinking.
You know even more because I grew up thinking I've got a I don't intend to live my life in the south I definitely planned to get away to the north and I couldn't talk about that to my parents especially my father he expected us to get an education he stressed education but he didn't expect us to go too far away from where he was but I remember feeling that day.
That that that just made me feel even more I have to get away from this.
How do you travel that's not the same as you know.
No not I during high school with the F what we called in H A we were not the what the whites were F H A with the N H A I had traveled to Texas once to.
A conference but that's as far away as I had been for the tape the N H A is the new home makers of America the white girls were future home makers of America kind of parallel in that same structure on the future farmers yes.
Did did did you have much contact in the in after 61 and 62 63 when the Southwest Georgia project began and some folks started to do working communities across.
You know the only cut well we were very conscious of what was happening in Albany and in fact we if if we were not to shop shop here in Albany we didn't and I can remember members of the Albany movement stopping in at our church to talk about what was happening and and rate and taking up a collection we supported it in that way my week my sisters and I.
Would always that it would bring us to a black dentist here in town and not here in Albany and my father in that dentist was what always be talking about the movement and and what I realized not they were also talking about Baker County and and how we could eventually get started there.
That didn't happen until after my father's death.
If you were about how you're each of your parents kind of navigated these years late 50s early 60s you know managing lives and family of children and a context like that.
Yeah my father would talk to us all the time about his years of growing up and how if a white man was driving down the road and they couldn't go around some some of them was just drive really slow some time to make them go have to go slow along with them.
My father would not he would not allow us to work in the fields owned by blacks I mean whites at all you know how we could finish doing our work and sometimes people would hire themselves out to do work and in the
and the on the fields of white people he would not allow us to do that he didn't want us working for white people and we didn't.
My father decided at one point that he should be registered to vote he was paying taxes in the county and and so one day he and my mother and aunt one of his sister and all is just decided that they would go and
and and do that and be prior to that though I had relatives who had attempted back in the 50s and so forth the houses were bombed or no more we call them Uncle Josh he and a man by the name of Benjamin T. Coney we just celebrated his 99th birthday here we could go Sunday.
Mr. Coney I'm a judge a man by the name of Ike King and and Carl Broadway led that effort to try to get the right to vote in Baker County and I'm a Josh's house was bombed they bombed Carl Broadway's car I think they bombed Ike King's car and they planted
a moonshine on Mr. Coney's place to try to get him sent off to prison for life or at least for a long time so you know I grew up knowing those efforts were taking place and then my father and mother trying to register the vote or even when my father made the the attempt to get
home he decided the farm was doing well and he was working to get loan from farmers home administration to build a home he he qualified for that he really really really wanted to have a home made of bricks that was his dream to have a brick home but even though he could borrow the money from farmers home administration to build a house they told him about the house
they told him a black man could not borrow the money to build a brick home it had to be either blocks or or wood and he and my mother chose the smallest blocks that they could find to to build that house.
Did you did you carry through these years I mean did you have any opportunities in these years to have any white pure contact as a child?
None at all.
So entry to the high school in 65 would be your first.
I didn't go to school with white kids at all.
I had read that I'm sorry.
Someone got that wrong.
I graduated from high school in 65 and it was that summer that my sisters along with some others in the county after the movement had started that we decided that schools had to be had to be integrated and they stepped forward.
I mean while you back then for a moment and I know this is an awful and terrible thing but he father was murdered in 1965.
Yes.
Yeah.
It was it was at a time and I lies when he was my father seemed to be really really happy my mother was pregnant and he told everyone it was the boy.
He in fact he gave out cigars that's how my best friend observed it and you could tell me that you know my mother was pregnant because he was giving out cigars to everyone saying this is it this time you know this is the boy he's having a new home build and having a room built specifically for the boy.
And the new home I was graduating from high school later you know at the end of that school term and he was happy about that because now the oldest would be going away to college and things were going well on the farm.
He was really really looking forward to the future.
He had had he in this farmer Cal Hall had actually done a few things together with goats and I was told that in 63 some of Cal Hall's cows had gotten into our pasture and when they came around them up there was one they couldn't they just couldn't get him out so he left him there.
I do know that my father was talking to people in snake about the civil rights movement coming into Baker County I don't know whether that was had something to do with what what happened later or not but on the morning of March 14th which was a Sunday.
I was driving the car we were on our way to church and met Cal Hall on the road and so I stopped he stopped my father was in the passenger seat so he leaned over Cal Hall said he wanted to come and get the cow.
My father told him if you come back tomorrow then I get some additional help and meet you around at the pasture so we went on the church and that's exactly what happened the next day my father took the man he had working on a farm with him my mother's brother went there and then Cal Hall who's white brought a black man who worked with him.
But instead of his cow he was trying to claim several five or six cows in the pasture and according to the others there my father told him no those you know they are get back and forth about the cows and my father finally said I don't have to continue arguing with you about it we just go to court and they according to them he was walking to his truck and
you know he turned around to say something that's when he was shot the grand jury my father didn't die immediately he linger for 10 days before he died so he died on March 25th of 1965 the grand jury the white grand jury in Baker County refused to and died him for murder so he was never punished now we later tried to do it.
So I tried to sue him and so interesting I was reading some notes one of the white students we had working with us that summer in Baker County kept a diary and just found it and published this book this year so he had a first hand accounting of what happened in that courtroom when during the trial the civil trial we had against them.
CB King who was the only he was our attorney throughout the movement here in Baker County what question potential jurors and ask them if you know of any black people who tell the truth they never heard the niggers they say things about niggers not telling the truth and so each time CB would ask that the judge strike that potential juror on the judge was see them.
And it happened in every case on CB would drill them but you know they were all seated and of course the verdict that we assume they would come in with was what they came in.
I guess you were 17.
I was 17 years old yes so we the movement started in Baker County that June and you know we had our bloodish out of it and we confronted the gator over and over.
We were also testing and trying to register the vote the first time I went to the courthouse to try to register there were three of us and Charles Sherrod was with us and the gator just pushed us down pushing us back out of the courthouse I couldn't register the vote.
In fact I didn't register the vote until later that fall this was after the vote in rights act had been passed.
And you went that fall I guess to Fort Gouste.
How did you manage to transition away from family especially in a context as difficult as that one.
That was so so hard and see after my father was murdered I didn't know what I could go to college at all you know he was our means of support we didn't have money.
And that's how I ended up at Fort Valley one of my uncles who he really he lived in Calhoun, Georgia, Georgia which was in a journey in Calney really stuck with us and stayed with us some and he decided I should go to Fort Valley.
And I should go to Fort Valley and help to get the paperwork done so that I could go to school there I didn't know what I could go to college after that.
So it was really really really tough leaving my mother and my sisters here while I was at Fort Valley.
I hadn't been there but two weeks I think when I received the call that a bunch of white men had come and burned across in front of the house it made it even more difficult.
You know the good thing is that we were so organized during that time because the movement had you know from June and this was September that once one of my sisters got on the phone and called a few of the black men were got to the others and they just came and completely surrounded these white guys with guns and everything.
Some of the younger black men who were involved really wanted to take a couple of them out that night but the older guys you know advised them against it and advised them to just allow them to leave.
You probably would have been reading about that when it had that happened.
I wonder how you began to try to add up of confronting a world with those kinds of dimensions when you're 17 or 18 years old and the movement is trying to find a foot hold in Baker County.
You know what you can recall about your sense of your prospects of your life and what choices you might make to try to move forward in your life at that point.
Well on the night of my father's death see I had not shared with my family that I really didn't intend to live in.
I knew that they would have been against that so I was secretly planning that in my own head knowing that I didn't intend to live life here.
But on the night of his death as our house filled with people who were coming for support I just felt as the list I had to do something.
I just had to do something as a result of what happened so I actually went away from everyone into one of the rooms and I can remember that night it looked like the moon was full because I was sitting there looking out.
I was the one to pray in to God asking for an answer. I just had to do something and suddenly it just came into my head that you can give up your dream of living in the north.
You can stay in the south in the future life" to work in for change.
And I can remember once that came to me I just felt such a calmness.
Now I didn't know how I would go about doing it. We were not active in the Civil Rights movement at that time because the movement had not started in Baker County.
But just coming to that conclusion made me feel like I could go on because I had a game plan.
And it didn't become clear to me how I could do that, how I could carry out that commitment until I was in my first mass meeting.
And it was during my first mass meeting when I saw people who had every right to be afraid.
People who were living on itch-way plantation, pineland plantation and on the farms, other farms owned by white people in the area not being afraid.
You know the strength we gather from each other being in those meetings and planning and deciding to fight together.
Once I saw that I knew that this was a way I could fight that.
Who were some of the early movement folks in the county you met early on?
Well of course Charles Sherrod. Back then he had people like Don Anderson (likely) or Ed Anderson, Bobby Jones.
There were a whole list of white students who came who were there that summer.
Reven Wells. I can't think of some of the others who were with him during that summer.
Eyes again, this and yes.
What were some of the first things that you did in stepping forward to find some place for yourself in that movement?
Well of course the marching attempt in the register to vote. We had decided we were going- we had a trip coming up to Washington.
We worked on it for several weeks because we were to testify before some members of Congress and march.
We were going to march at DOJ Civil Rights Division about the injustices in Baker County.
So we were secretly- we were having mass meetings and then working on the plans for- for getting a group of people to Washington raising money.
I never forget the- the Sunday night that we met at the church in a mass meeting and then that caravan, that included five carloads of people,
were leaving from that meeting. That meeting was held at thankful Baptist Church in- in Baker County, the church that I grew up in located on Highway 91.
And so the normal route for us would have been to leave the church that night, go through Newton, Georgia and keep coming north through Albany to go north to- to Washington, D.C.
But we knew the Gator would be waiting on us at- from where we were at the church, somewhere between there and the Baker County line.
So we assumed that he would be waiting somewhere north of Newton, Georgia between Newton, Georgia and the Baker County line coming to Albany.
So we drove in a caravan to Newton, Georgia, but we went east into Mitchell County, Georgia and then we went north coming on this way and driving through the night.
On- on Josie, she was probably five feet if that tall, but just a fire brand. She was driving one of the cars.
We were going through North Carolina and she had some kids in her car who needed to use the bathroom.
And so she ended up stopping on the side of the road and then her attempt to catch the group. She was driving a little fast and was stopped by a state trooper.
So he's shining the lights and asking her where was she going and she told- she didn't realize she was driving that fast, but she said she was trying to take these kids up there to see the White House.
You know they had never been and so she gave them that story. So far- oh my goodness I'm so excited.
Okay so on Josie, you know she- she's just telling us cop how she's trying to get these kids up there to see the White House, you know, and he just let her go.
She was the same one who when on bloody Saturday in Albany when they were beating Shirai so bad, she threw her body across him and said, you know I told him to stop before they kill him.
Did you protest that outside of the front?
Yes and we testified- I saw a little clip, a little news article from that.
Well one of the things the Gator, they said he was saying back here if he had known we would never have made it, you know.
So we were able to pull that off without the word getting to him and I can remember Kanye's was in Congress and he said that we need a protection going back to Baker County.
Do you have a sense of- did that effort- did efforts like that in that moment that they feel as if they might actually generate some response?
Did you have a sense that the national government might respond in that context with any-
it was so hard to- to know just we always call you know if we when I went to try to register the vote and couldn't you go back and you call a Justice Department.
But you knew that more many of them who were from this- I mean who were working for DOJ Civil Rights Division were from this area and they were not going to do but so much.
When we took my sisters up to try to get them enrolled in school the Gator was there to stop us so what do you do?
You go back and you call a Justice Department. And in some cases they would they would do what they were expected to do.
You could never totally count on that. But in some cases they would not the result of that.
That's that what we were doing that summer actually led to getting an injunction against the Gator.
You know he that's what finally- stopped some of what he was doing. He couldn't just openly do it.
Think at one point they reported in the Constitution his speech rap was generating about 150,000 a year just for him on the road.
You know so a lot of that stuff had to had to stop before that it looked like he could just do any and everything he wanted to do and would always get by with it.
You would you would be at Albany State excuse me at Fort Gowd State for two years.
Two years.
And then come back this way. Did to what what was the extent to which you were able to kind of maintain a close contact with your family and-
or I was here every weekend.
Okay.
Coming back you know and and writing and you know-
So you you stayed very much kind of in that.
Yes.
And what motivated the choice to enroll at almost a 67?
Well I was too far away from the work I felt and wanted to be back here.
So that's why I decided to you know come back.
Yeah. Tell me about some of that activity 65 to 67 as you're trying to move forward and-
Well see I'm sorry.
Well and I was going to say too a couple different things are happening at different levels.
Obviously there's all the work that that Grimshaw and others are trying to push forward here.
There are also in this span of time.
Snick is changing a lot and kind of the planet.
Right.
There's a shift there so yeah.
Right. Well you know of course we had lots of white people here working with us in Southwest Georgia.
And it was during the time when-
after the from 65 66.
Well of course John Lewis was the director of SNCC and then Stokely was taking over.
And Stokely was saying all whites had to leave.
You know the black power movement has started.
We didn't agree with that.
So it was during that period of time that we decided that the whites who were working with us didn't have to leave.
And we eventually had to have that break with-
with Snick.
That's how we ended up incorporating the work here.
Snick's work here in Southwest Georgia was referred to as the Southwest Georgia project.
So we just simply started our own organization to be able to continue-
to keep the whites who were here working with us and to continue to work here as Southwest Georgia project.
Sure.
Can you paint the essential picture of Reverend Shorod as you saw him doing all this work in those years?
I tell you he seemed to be fearless.
He had been beaten and threatened so many times but he was so focused on-
on-on-change for this area.
And I guess that's what I saw in him and I definitely wanted change.
In the area I had made a commitment to stay in the-
in the South Rether to work for change.
The work was dangerous, you know, quite dangerous at times.
In fact, we actually got married a little over a year after I met him.
And it was the summer of 1967, I believe.
We had a place here in Albany had lots of students that some of both black and white.
Here working, we were-
we were printing a newsletter one Saturday morning when all but one person had left to go out-
I was not feeling well that morning.
We had this young child who hung around us a lot.
He came every morning.
His name was Grady Christian.
He's studded but he-
it was just like he was our child so to speak.
He stayed there with me.
And I'll never forget that morning.
I heard these people come up.
I knew they were white from the way the voices sounded.
But we had white people with us all the time so it wasn't.
You know, it didn't disturb me at all but they were asking for him.
And Grady was stuttering trying to tell him so he eventually they asked him rather to come go with him to look for him.
They left and came back.
I was in the bedroom.
That was the only space we could call hours in that house.
And I heard them going the back of the house where the office was and then came in person to the room.
Where I was, I was screaming at them to get out.
And they one kept approaching me but just stopped.
And then they left.
They Grady walked out with them and he came back in the house, went to the back and came and said,
they had to cheerly to houses on fire.
They had actually set the house on fire when they came into the place.
Now, the fire department came, the police came of course and there was no attempt to even look into it.
We were able, my husband and I were able to get a few of our things out.
We had to go to Baker County to stay.
We had to go to another house that night and on the way to Baker County we were about maybe six miles out of town if that fire.
When we had a flat tire, it was really dark.
So we sitting on the side of the road, my husband was trying to think about what he's got to do to change this tire.
He would do that even now.
Changing the tire just wasn't his thing.
So he's sitting there and then this truck drove up and pulled in right behind us.
We could hear them and just a couple of white guys.
They appeared to have been drinking some and I'm thinking they didn't get us today.
This is it.
But they didn't recognize him and they ended up changing the tire.
And we went on to Baker County.
The incident that happened then made my husband finally realize that we couldn't all be together like that.
And finally, after over a year of marriage, about a year of marriage, we finally moved into an apartment where there were just the two of us living together.
How was your, let me do the extent that you want to talk about this.
How was your mother weather in all these years having lost her husband and then knowing that her daughter's husband and all were in the context of such ongoing risk?
Yeah, she was always afraid for us.
But she became a very, very strong person throughout all of this.
And in fact, that's why when 11 years after my father's death, when she told us she was going to run for office, I was shocked.
You know, we had, we didn't have, we had never had a black person elected to office before.
And the only one that I can remember, well, we did run a few people for Board of Education, Mr. T. Coney,
that the man who just became 99 on the Sunday ran against the Gator, you know.
So we had made some attempts before.
But when my mother decided she would run for office, I couldn't believe it.
You know, but she did and she jumped over heartily into it.
And of course, we were there helping as well.
And it was also the year that the Gator decided he would retire.
And his son, Scrut, would become the new sheriff.
So they were campaigning for Scrut and we were out there for my mother.
And on election night, we were all gathered in Newton, Georgia at the courthouse, watching the people sit at the table counting the ballots.
And the Gator, you know, we stand in there in the foyer of the courthouse.
And the Gator came from a back room and walked past us and he just spoke.
And then he realized he had just spoken to Charles Sharad.
So he came back and he said, I take that back. I didn't know who you were.
So he and my husband are standing there staring directly into each other's eyes.
Now the Gator is, he was so, you know, sure of himself and that he could do whatever he wanted to do.
It would have been nothing for him to just pull his gun and that he did have a gun on him.
And just shoot Charles Sharad right there with everyone standing there.
So there I was about to have a heart attack.
We had our two kids there and they are staring at each other and someone apparently, I guess, went out and told his son what was happening.
So the son ran back in and grabbed his father's hand.
I got a sneeze again, I'm sorry.
I was just going to say my mother became the first black elected official.
When Bertrand took his doctorate at Union Theological in 1967.
It's a master's.
Excuse me, it's a master's.
Oh.
You should have tried to be so careful about these things. I'm not doing so well.
Up in New York. Was there any point where you traveled up there?
No, not while he was in school at Union.
I was in school at Fort Val.
I was thinking about that in relation to a question I want to ask, which is when I think back in all this history and about your early sense of yourself that you would build a life outside the side.
Obviously you've made a commitment to all the work that you're doing here.
But in the face of all of this kind of pressure, this relentless pressure over the years, did you ever think that you know enough we will go somewhere?
There was a time when this was around 80, eight to 90.
When this was after the loss of the land at New Communities.
My husband seemed to be having such a hard time getting beyond that.
I was having our kids who were the door out door, I had gone to college and 85 things were really, really, really tough.
And one of my friends worked at, she was the director of the Presbyterian Hunger Program.
And she decided maybe he should work for the Presbyterian Church as a minister.
I think it was a Presbyterian by that time.
So it would have meant moving to Louisville, Kentucky.
I thought this is certainly, maybe, you know, it wasn't, the work I was doing here, working with the Federation, Kentucky was one of the states that the Federation of Southern Cooperatives worked in.
I knew that I could continue, it wouldn't have been right here in Southwest Georgia, but I would have been able to continue that work with the Federation just would be doing it from Kentucky.
So I can remember one night that Mary Ellen Lorde and I were on, she was on the phone and we had him on the phone and we just begging him to do it and he said no, he had work to do here in this area.
He used to leave and I just couldn't understand when things were so hard, no one would hire him to work in this area because of his civil rights history.
But he kept saying, I had work to do here and I refused to leave.
Let me have you talk about the ways in which you moved into very ambitious new modes of engagement in activism in the late 60s and one of them courses in the communities.
Well see, when you're out there and we were in all of these counties working and sometimes people would enroll like kids in a white school and get kicked off to land owned by whites or did something else and they get kicked off.
So the whole issue was, you know, we didn't have an answer for that.
And the whole idea of trying to build a community actually surfaced and seven people went to Israel, they studied the Kibbutz and came back with a sort of different model to, for us to consider and we ended up creating an organization that we called new communities.
And we were being very ambitious, we didn't intend to just get bogged down with one piece of land, we intended to actually go about the country buying land, turning it over to local community development corporations.
But we got bogged down with the first piece, which was a 6,000 acre plot north of here in the county.
I, you know, I guess I was so naive at the time, I just really didn't think there would be a lot of opposition to people trying to do something to help themselves.
So, you know, I'm sure others probably anticipated that, I didn't.
So it was really, really tough to actually have to experience the things that were done to us during that time.
I was just, I was really, really, unbelievable looking back. But it would have seemed that, well, you can look at the climate today and see some of the same thing, you're trying to help yourself, you would think that wouldn't be so much opposition to that but it was such a threat to people at the time and I realized that now.
But we, we, we just jumped into it, wholeheartedly.
Can you say a little bit more about that vision, you suggested it.
Yeah, we, we had big plans. In fact, we were able to get a planning grant from the office of economic opportunity in Washington to plan this community.
And that was such a, I mean, that can remember feeling so good, so free, you know, as we went through that process, they called them charrettes where people who actually were going to participate in this new community helped to determine what that community should be like.
So we had all of these sessions talking about housing, you know, and where the villages would be located and we had experts working with us to make that determination about where villages would be located.
What kind of educational system we wanted. I mean, we could dream what kind of health system where industry would be located. We had railroad going through with a spur on to it.
What kind of farm and we would do. How we would do that farm and treating people the way they should be treated. So we had a farm committed to deal with the farm and education committed to deal with education.
Health committed to deal with health issues and so forth. And, and, for example, with the farm committee, we knew that you needed someone, and when you're out there working, you need someone who's the last word out there.
That's a matter of management. But the actions of that manager could always be brought in the question at the farm committee meeting. And all of the, the people who were working on the farm plus three members of the board and the farm manager were the ones who were members of that farm committee.
And the farm committee met every Monday night, you know, because it was the most active after we didn't get the funding after the funding from OEO was blocked by the governor for the state of Georgia.
You know, it really threw us into a situation where we were faced with foreclosion. Once we worked through that and we're really rolling, we were, we couldn't build the houses. We couldn't implement the other plans, but we could hold on to the land by farming.
And, and that's what we did. So the farm became the major activity for the farm and we were doing some very innovative things back then. The way we treated people who worked on the plantation was just totally different.
I can't remember, we called it the big house. We didn't look at that house now. It was just a brick house. But, you know, people would naturally think my husband and I would move into the big house. That's not the way we operated.
We, the farmer, he was actually a mechanic. The person who had the biggest family should move into the house. They moved in there, but the wife thought it was too much house and they moved out into one of the other houses.
But it was never a thing where a charade and I, my husband and I would be the ones to move into something like that. That's not the message we were trying to send out.
We were not trying to recreate something that modeled what was already there. We were actually trying to build something that was new and different and equal.
It meant so much to us to have that place, that land, that was owned not by me, not by him, but by us. It was a land trust.
Who was the mechanism of racial financing?
Actually, Slater King, who was CV King's brother had lots of connections and was able to, through those connections, put together one year financing because we had been assured by OEO that we would get the funding from the government and could really move on to a building this dream.
But when Lester Maddox, the money from the federal government, and we, therefore, didn't have that, that's why we faced for closure.
For a couple of years, the prudential insurance company held the first mortgage.
We were through lots of different creative things able to put together the better finance so that we were more secure with the land.
You mentioned that some folks that it is real to kind of look at the Kibbutz model. Can you talk about some of the other, and you have a little bit,
would there any other models in the United States at that time that you could turn to as inspiration?
It was basically, it wasn't the Kibbutz, but the Moshav method, and you know, because with the Kibbutz, the children had to be away from the family, and that wouldn't work here with us.
It was more of a communal thing, that wouldn't have worked here.
We had lots of people, we had folks who were part of the National Sharecroppers Fund, Bob Swann, out of the Northeast.
Some of these people brought things that they were familiar with as we were developing what it is we were trying to create here.
Part of my question, I guess, is it points out how innovative this was and how ambitious it was?
I tell people now we were way ahead of our time. The land trust, you don't own the land, you get a renewable lease, and so that's one way why people in the area were trying to divide us by telling people who were involved, you won't own anything there.
You know, your house won't be yours. Just a lot of things, as we were trying to educate people, they were trying to put things in place to get them to see that I'm not going to work.
But we just kept moving on, and we were, like I said, we were doing things that were innovative. We were back in those days, one of my uncles, my father's brothers and all those who went on to college,
studied in the field of agriculture, and so they were the extension agents or vocational ag teachers, and one who had been an extension agent actually came to work with us, and he was so, I mean, even today he's almost 90 years old and we talk, and he's always putting together.
He's trying to tell me, surely, because we have this new place now for new communities, and he's talking about pomegranates and making pomegranate juice and making pomegranate jelly and all this stuff.
So during those days, he was doing innovative things, so we had muscadine grapes when no one else, this is in the 70s, no one was planning muscadine grapes in this area.
The things we did with vegetables, the things we did even with the hogs, we had, I think it was about a 75 brood-sow operation, but instead of just taking those hogs to the market to sell them, we actually took them into the, to be slaughtered, and then brought them back to the farm because we had a farmer's market there on how we US Highway 19.
And we would cut out the hams and the shoulders and the bacon and all that, we were known for cured meats during that time.
Excuse me, we were known for sugar cane syrup because we had a sugar cane meal set up right there by the highway.
We had an old-fashioned smokehouse built right there by the highway, so people could come in and have that experience and get cured meats, you know, and so the things we were doing were totally not being done.
Let's pause this one, sir.
Okay, we'll do that.
Mr. Oda, I want to ask too about you obviously would move in a very intensive and purposeful way into a career in building this model and this vision and working in these kinds of ways.
So I'm really interested to have you talk about your choice to study, work, and begin so much, the Federation of Southern Cooperatives, local, all the later all the work on the Rural Development Leadership Network.
Well, you know, working out out at New Communities, you can see the thing, you know, we couldn't, we didn't have money, so you've got to learn everything you can learn while you also working.
So even though I had young children, spent most of my time out there, I would leave work, I realized accounting was something that was a great need for us.
We didn't have money to pay for the services, so I actually would leave work out there, run the Albany State for classes at night.
I took enough classes, business classes to have a second degree in business. I didn't pursue it that way because I had decided I would get a Masters in Business Administration, a MBA.
And Valdosta State was just starting a program and actually made it possible for students over here at a 10 classes at Albany State for that.
So I was working and on that track also to learn everything I could learn, you know, to be helpful to what we were doing.
I was also organizing day care centers, so I organized the first one in Baker and then I was actually putting one together and it did operate for several years at New Communities right up until the end.
I was organizing farmers because I realized one of the needs was to have someone serving on the ASCS Committee.
So pulling farmers together, developing secret campaigns, you know, I never forget we had one meeting up there at the day kiss and at New Communities about 20 or 30 farmers.
And told them, you know, we need to select one person to run nobody else. Then we need to get a copy of all of the eligible voters and we took that list and divided it up so that everyone was contacted.
And then I remember on the day of election, I couldn't stand it. We just had to stop by. There was a black girl working in the office as she came out to the vehicle and said, what is it looking like?
And she said, well, a lot of their ballots are coming in and not signed on the back and so forth. We actually elected the first black person to that committee.
So there were just so many things you had to do while you were still working to get at many of the problems that we were facing.
So you need to learn everything you can learn. You need to work hard as you can work.
It was when I became involved with the rule of development leadership network, we were facing foreclosure at New Communities.
We ended up going, we were not barring money from the government to farm, but after the first drought, I think it was around 76.
We didn't go even that first year of drought to try to bar a moment. But after the second year, we had to go and try to bar a money to farm.
And my husband, my uncle, and one other person went over and the county supervisor said, you get a loan here of my dead body.
So that put us in a three-year fight just to try to bar emergency money for the farm.
And with the size farm, we were operating three years, it was just too long to go because we kept experiencing drought.
So we had no way else to turn. But when my mother used to always say that her father would not bar money from farmers home administration because he felt it was just a way to take black farmers land.
And I thought about that so many times as we were dealing with them. And even though you burn, you have assets worth 4.5 million, maybe you burn two or three hundred thousand, but they're tying up all of your available assets. And that's how they got us.
They tied up all of the available assets. And then once they had the web around us, they were ready to go in for the kill. That's basically what happened.
So, you know, where do I go from here? What do I do from here? As I knew the end was near. I had actually applied to the rural development leadership network to work on my masters after losing the farm.
And the thing that really, really pushed me to go on and do it, the land was supposed to be sold at the courthouse steps in June of 85.
The rural development leadership networks institute was being held from May 15 to June 15 at UC Davis, which meant I would not be here. It meant I had to miss my daughter's high school graduation.
But it also meant I wouldn't be here when the land was sold. And so I was accepted into the program and went there and had to have a sponsor.
So I had to talk to Federation of Southern Cooperatives and to sponsor in me in the program. And of course the land didn't sell in June.
And I came back from the institute and went up to Atlanta and talked to the Federation about possibly coming on to their staff. And they reluctantly decided to do it.
So I started working with them in July of 85. The land was sold in September of 85. Now when that land was sold, the new owner gave us a very short time to get our things away from the land.
And then they dug holes and pushed all of our buildings over in that farmer's market that had the old fashioned smokehouse and the sugar came mill and all of that stuff there by the road.
And wherever the houses were, we had a few houses on the place where people were staying. They dug just dug holes and pushed them over into it.
So it was a particularly tough, you know, you got to figure out how to live from here.
Daughter in college already starting the master's program, starting with the Federation.
Federation didn't have a real presence in this area of the state. So I didn't have an office. I had been hired and had to develop a program for work in this area with the Federation.
And I just got busy doing that. And in the meantime, we were also the Slater King Center rehabilitation program. We were getting that going.
So again, you couldn't stop. You just had to keep going at things that needed help. So where I didn't have new communities anymore, I poured all of that into trying to develop programs for other black farmers in this area.
Yeah. Obviously, we'll just note here for the record that the Pigford suit will later draw this arc out in a long, long span and return a legal victory around the question of the experience of new communities.
Maybe it won't since that's a more contemporary thing. Have time for a long discussion of that today, but very complicated litigation over many years.
But I do want to ask you to reflect a little bit about the outcome of that case and the context of loss, the passage of lots of time, which can't be recovered. And then a legal answer to a problem.
Yeah. As I worked with the Federation, still working on the issue of land law. So many farmers who are losing their land farmers were being foreclosed by farmers home trying to develop strategy for dealing with that.
Trying to help farmers put together good business plans, trying to deal with farmers home administration employees on their behalf.
You know, sometimes even those situations were dangerous. I remember one farmer called me, he had received a letter with a time for an appointment to be at the office and Blakely, Georgia.
And as he called and asked if I would come and go with him. So I went down there, it was Marvell Smith in his wife.
We met there at the office and when we, when we were called in to talk with the county supervisor, he sat there and just, oh my god. See, one of the things I had to do was learn regulations and better than the folks in those offices.
I knew the regulations and anyone who worked with me had to learn regulations. So we're in there. And this guy is, he's just talking on, nonstop, just on and on.
He's selling the farmer that he would be foreclosing on the farm first and then the home because he had separate loans. His wife started crying.
You know, and I'm wondering when this man gonna ever stop. So look like he wasn't. So I just stopped him because he wasn't sighted in current regulation. He couldn't do what he was telling him.
He could do in the way he was telling them he was going to do it. So I finally stopped him and said, will you put that in writing?
So he pushed back from the desk and started looking at the floor and he eventually turned this chair all the way around looking at the floor and then looked at me and said, I ain't putting nothing in writing.
So we just started arguing, you know, and arguing. I don't know what family stopped us, but we did and then he told Marvell Smith that, you know, patting him on the back, Mr. Smith had a sign that's probably caught a lot.
And so he's telling him, you need to do something about that, you know, and but you'll receive the notice in less than six weeks.
And he did, but we fought him so and fought him so the credit act of 87 came and so this guy finally saw that these farmers had a better way of trying to deal with their debt so that they could save the farm.
So he ended up leaving the agency, but I tell you I was in, I was on his case filing complaints and doing everything up until the time he finally left.
You know, but so looking at the loss, you know, experience in the loss, our selves at new communities and then working with other farmers and then with the federation working with so many more, not just here in South West Georgia, but across the South.
We kept realizing we had to do something about the land loss that was taken place. And so we would work with get with other organizations and talk about it and kept saying that, you know, we're going to have to find a little follow-law suit.
So finally, we were in a meeting in Atlanta, the federation, land loss prevention project, project out of North Carolina, farmers legal action group out of Minnesota.
And we decided, okay, the time has come. So we decided that land loss prevention and flag would be the two organizations, both of nonprofit law firms.
So we, they sent in a request to try to get information on complaints from USDA and the answer they got back was we don't have any.
So the first lawsuit was filed just to get that, the information and the judge, that was a hearing and the judge said those folks from farmers home down and he threatened to put them in jail if they didn't furnish the information.
So they ended up sending, I think about 25 boxes to land loss prevention and about 30 to the other law firm. And then we decided to start with six test cases.
And that's when this slick lawyer out of Texas, Maya, came along and went to those six farmers and got them to sign a retainer with him, which basically took those cases away from the two law firms we had.
And changed everything. Those cases were eventually won, but he was eventually disbarred based on what he did in those cases.
And then after this had taken place, then picked the pick for case, surfaced.
So then this whole thing about whether we take Pigford all the way to court, whether we look at settling with the government.
And the issue around whether to settle or not was based on the fact that most of those farmers knew they had been discriminated against, but didn't, many of them wouldn't have had all of the documentation necessary.
So we had this big fight then about whether to settle or not. And some of the farm groups were in favor of settling and some were not.
And we eventually decided to settle the Pigford case. And in that settlement, there were two classes of farmers.
(Pigford) Track A claimants wouldn't have to have a lot of proof to prove that they were discriminated against.
And if they were successful, they would receive 50,000 plus they were supposed, they told us that they would get all of that ridden of that that didn't happen in the end.
And then class B were farmers who had more documentation of the discrimination and therefore we get their one day in court to prove their case.
So because, and see none of the farmers were trying to get rich, the whole idea of maybe getting their debt ridden off was more appealing to them than anything else.
Now what happened they told them, you know, you don't have much to prove with the class A. So maybe they were discriminated against trying to get an operating on a farm ownership loan, farm ownership loan, even a housing loan.
But they only used one instance of discrimination because it wasn't supposed to be that difficult. And what the government later said, we'll only write off the debt for the type of discrimination you receive.
Well they could have cited many of them but they only used one. And so in the end the government got them on that. And they were supposed to, if they were successful, they were supposed to get 50,000, they would get 12,500 paid to the internal revenue service as taxes on the 50.
But in the end the government taxed the whole 65. So lots of things just went wrong with that. Because they were not trying to get rich on it out of roughly 22,000 claimants because one problem was that the word didn't get out to everyone.
There was no announcement. So that's why so many of them didn't hear about it in time. You only had six months to file a claim. So during that six month period they were roughly close to 22,000 who filed a claim. And because A was so simple, most of them, I think only 180 something filed a class B claim in pig fruit.
And that's pig fruit one as we refer to it as we refer to it today. So at new communities I was so busy helping farmers, not just here in Southwest Georgia. When I went as far as Texas with the Federation trying to explain to farmers, but it was driving from Alabama one night where I had been over there working.
And just thinking about the day I was I never forget I was over near Eufaula, Alabama when it suddenly dawn on me. We were farming in 1981. At new communities it meant we could file a claim in pig fruit. It had three months ago by and it had not occurred to me one time until then. Couldn't wait to get home.
Didn't have a cell phone or anything. I couldn't wait to get home to tell my husband that we could file a claim. I just burst into the outside and we can file a claim in pig fruit.
You know, so we had problems because when we had to move our stuff from the farm we placed them in different places here in Albany. We had had a flood in 1994 and lost some of that.
But anyway, this was 1999. We were able to get into that courthouse out there in Lee County to start. See, we didn't look we left and didn't look into what happened.
Oh my goodness, when we finally were working on the claim we saw exactly what happened. They were letting big plantations out there borrow money that they were denying us.
We had no idea. Just no idea. There were things they should have offered us service and options they didn't do it. We saw then the bad things that they did to us. They were documented there in the courthouse.
The man who bought the property at auction, we know it was worth at least 4.5 million because we've been offered that. We just didn't want to give it up by some hunters who wanted the place.
He paid, he got it for a million dollars and they turned around and let him borrow $950,000, three weeks later. You know, just the injustices. We just had no idea. We were made to feel bad as failed. You know, we were made to feel that we failed and it was all of our fault.
But there was all of the documentation once we started looking into it. So we filed the claim before the six month deadline for new communities and that put us in a 10 year battle. It was 10 years.
We filed a claim. We had our day in court, I think in 2002. The hearing officer was the wife of the chief adjudicator for Pigford.
The lawyer for DOJ Civil Rights Division seemed so incompetent. In fact, that morning when we went to that room where our hearing was being held when the court reporter walked in the room and started setting up.
She looked at my husband and I and said, who's the lawyer for DOJ Civil Rights Division for you all. And we said a woman by the name of Margaret O'Shea. And she just looked at us and said, oh you are lucky, lucky, lucky.
We had no idea what she was talking about. Didn't ask her to explain. When that hearing officer, I mean when that lawyer came in and started, she was making so many mistakes.
But the strange thing is the person from farmer's home was telling the truth. And so she saw her case going down the drain. She called for a break, took him out of there when he came back. He was lying.
He and I had done some stuff working together. He was working from the agency I was working for the Federation, helping farmers. And he couldn't even look at me. He couldn't look me in the eye after that. Never did.
Because she threatened them and he came back in there just lying through his teeth. So anyway, we laughed because she did such a poor job that the attorney she even threatened the court reporter that day.
And telling her, and she told her, I pay your salary. And she was trying to make her do whatever she was. I can't remember. So anyway, when we left, we had won the case. If you have been sitting in the room, said they won that.
We were shocked to know in when we, that was in July. And October, we received a letter from the hearing officer saying she ruled against us. We couldn't believe.
Now remember, she's the wife of the chief adjudicator. So I'll allow you to decide that Pilot-Talk got us. That they couldn't pay out that kind of money at the beginning of Pigford.
So then we had to appeal to the monitors office. And the monitors, the judge set up this process so that farmers could appeal to the monitor.
Now the monitor couldn't receive any new information, but had to look at everything to see if there were any, there were any mistakes that were caused a miscarriage of justice.
Excuse me. The monitor was a friend of mine. She had to refuse herself. So she had to find someone else who could handle our case. And she eventually did that.
And that person took four years looking through everything, but then he finally came out with a document that was about 50 or 60 pages thick, pointing out all of the mistakes that had been made that would cause a miscarriage of justice.
And the way the process went, he would send that to the chief adjudicator. And until our case, we learn once the chief adjudicator received that information, he would just pay the claimants.
But in our case, he wrote us a letter. This was by now, it was 2006. He wrote us a letter saying it was an extensive case, and it would take him some time to review it.
We didn't hear anything from him. From October, I think that letter was dated. I covered 10th, 2006. Not one word from him till July of 2009.
When I lawyer called the night of July 8, 2009, I answered the phone. She said, Shirley, have you heard? I said, no. She said, we won.
So, by now, this is 10 years later. So I said, really? And I was a justice kind of, because not expecting much. She said, you want to guess how much? And I said, roses are at least $10.
And is it at least $1 million? And she said, it's 12. Just totally unbelievable. We didn't get the paperwork until a few days later when she faxed it to us.
But when you read it, when you read his decision, I cry every time I read it now, because point by point, he looked at the research from the monitor's office and just point by point, he seemed to get it.
What are those resources allowed you to do here as you look ahead?
Well, we knew we would buy more land, the dream continued. And once we got over the shock of it, we did people who lost their positions when we lost the land, we made sure they got a little of the money.
But we knew that we intended to buy land. And we started looking. And the lawyers locally that we had, I never forget, one of them said, let me take your eye to look at this plantation. And I'm thinking plantation.
So we went out and looked at this place, a few miles out of town, that had been set up basically for hunting. And it had several cabins on it that could sleep maybe about 35 people and had other things set up. But it was all geared for hunters.
And so we were seriously considering that place when someone else said we got this other place, we really want you all to see. So once in the morning, we went out there and we got on this Jeep that's set for hunters, you know, we got some sitting down here in these different levels.
And so we're riding over this place. And one of the things on this place was this antebellum home had been built in 1851 and had been totally restored by the previous owner.
The previous owner had made lots of money from developing the system to pay for gas at the pump. So he had lots of money and he poured it into that place because he was putting together his dream place.
So just in that antebellum home alone, we've heard that he put about 3 million just into it. But there are cabins, there's a lake, there's a farming area.
It comes right up to the property line, comes right up to the city limit of Albany and I remember feeling antebellum home, why would we want that? You know, that was, I was just totally against it.
And then my husband and others were totally into it. And so I'm looking at the other place, we could get workshops and things going out there right away and house people versus this place. So I said, let's just get someone from the outside to come in and help us decide which place.
So that person came in and did a little study on both places and came back with his recommendation. Totally not the one I was, I was pushing, I was hurt.
Because I just, that whole antebellum thing was just, I just had an issue with it. I didn't know the history of the place at that time. But he gave us all the reasons why it was a better buy.
It had been put on the market at 21 million when we went out to look at it. They had dropped the price to 6.9.
The 85 acre lake has cabins down by the lake. He's running electricity, electricity all over the place. Welles, you know, irrigation.
And of course that house that he put $3 million into restoring. So the person we brought in to help us try to settle on which one he said down.
I think someone, it was on the market for 6.9. Someone suggested maybe we ought to offer them five. He said I would offer less than that. You can get this place for less than that.
And they didn't include equipment in it. So then we started really negotiating. We got tough then. And finally settled at 4.5 million with the equipment.
And so that place is called Cypress Pond Plantation. We found that it was owned by probably the richest person, the original owner.
The wealthiest slave owner in Georgia. He actually owned three places where he held slaves. So he owned about 1,000 slaves all together.
And he kept slaves out there. At Cyprus Pine, he died though when, just as he was completed in that antebellum home.
And he willed it to his son who died about 8 years later. And so there's the auction things out there. There were 150 slaves there at the time.
We were told to that Jefferson Davis, actually before Paul Tarver died, the son, Jefferson Davis stayed there as they were planning the succession of civil war activities or whatever.
So it has a history. It definitely has a history.
There's all levels of interesting irony in that. Yes. Let's pause for just one second.
Let me ask for some reflections from you to kind of bring us to a close here today about how much all this work that you've done and that positions you as an interesting observer of transitions and race and gender and in the South across quite a number of years now.
Your perspective on which things you do see substantial change, which places where you've dumped it. And some of your evaluations is to why?
Well, the work that I did with black farmers led white farmers to see some success in trying to deal with the government. And that's why that whole issue of the Spooners coming to me back in the latter part of the eighties for help with saving their farm surfaced.
But people didn't know the Spooners were the first white family that I helped, but I helped many, many more white farmers. I can remember a farmer's home administration employee county supervisors saying I was helping a farmer and one kind of why are you helping him?
I have a airplane and a Cadillac. So the point was I, you know, going way back, I didn't just limit my work to after the Spooners when I went through issues of having to deal with what happened to my father and actually helping a white farmer.
Looking at all of the land loss issues we've had as black people and then actually helping a white farmer to save his farm and realizing in that process that the issue was more about poor being poor and not about race.
And that's why for the last 25 years now I have tried to point that out as much as I could through the years to try to get people here in this area to see that if we can work together we can do more to bring change in this area than we can trying to work against each other.
So that's what I've tried to do through the years as a woman working in this field has been interesting, very interesting. I can remember even in my hometown when I, the first cooperative that I worked to organize here in this area was actually in Baker County dealing with a group of farmers there who wanted to grow feeder pigs.
And I kept telling them if you're going to grow these feeder pigs you have to accept training and they kept trying to get me to understand that they knew how to raise hogs and I'm saying you have to accept training and then I said okay I've got to go through this with them.
So the, the Heifer Project gave us hogs we had to go up the Harris County, Georgia to pick them up and then I let those farmers decide who there were 15,000 three boys so they decided that three farmers would get the first start five,000 a boy.
I let them decide who would get them. I knew what needed to happen but I had to go through this with them because they did not understand that they had to be trained.
So as luck would have it the day after the hogs got here the guy from the Heifer Project came to go to these farms so we went to the first farm conditions were really really bad.
The third farmer had bragged in the meetings that he was growing his hogs on concrete and I almost told that guy from the Heifer Project and we about to go to the best farm now I'm so glad the Lord kept my mouth closed.
Because when we got to that farm and I saw the conditions there is like oh my goodness the farmer took us he showed us where he had the hogs he had just received lots of glass and stuff out there in the pasture and then there was some water there he said you know what that water's come from.
I know who were from my kids is saying I'm like oh no he didn't say that and then he said you want to see my hogs my other hogs and of course the guy from the Heifer Project wanted to see him.
So he took us to where these hogs were growing on concrete the concrete had broken up you know and so it's the wonder they didn't get caught and so he had water streaming down and sprinklers from the top.
So it was going out of that little pin and other hogs right there while I went in that and then he said I got some other hogs up here and they were under a trailer a peanut trailer on the shed and so he kept calling the hogs and call me plants and food I they didn't move.
He went and kicked them and they were they were crippled so the guy from the Heifer Project said there's some serious problems here I said let me tell you what they are I wanted him to know I knew better so I said what I will do is get some training started right away so after he left I call extension and they gave me to run around it was University of Georgia extension so that's okay.
Very next meeting I started to train in myself so when I started talking to the farmers about when the cast rate and Clip and I tease and they all you know how to farm I didn't ever have a problem again after that and so over through the years many many farmers I've had farmers who wouldn't buy a track unless they came and talked to me about it because I did business plans and and when I got staff here you know helping me I made sure they knew how to do business plan.
And then we would go with them to those local offices so they knew their lifeline the money was through us because we knew we knew the regulations we knew we could do the business plan and actually help them to to get the finances and other things that they needed to so I didn't it's it was an interesting situation to be in with these male farmers and and being a figure out where they are.
I was talking to a female leading that effort and and many of my efforts I was talking to someone who was here from USDA and June and I took that person down to see the commercial kitchen that we started and that when I think I told you we moved into that new school building in April of 57 when the school system built a new school I encourage the community to work together I wanted that building to still be stand and I wanted to do that.
And so we created a nonprofit which was only the second one in Baker County and in that building the day is a commercial kitchen a worker on so I'm co-op after school program head start just a bunch of stuff happening in that building.
Now so I took this person down there to see it and I said I will take you up to the peak on our operation and I told about how Ben and Jerry's wanted to help with the problem of black land loss and told Rapunzel Page at a farm a concert will buy product from your farmers to go in the ice cream and we settle on pecans and how I organized farmers to be able to do that and in the process ran into races and the process was done.
Because we needed to contract with the company to do the processing of the pecans and everywhere we went they said tell you what we would do. We are about to pick on some black farmers and we will sell them Ben and Jerry's and they can say they have pecans from black farmers in the ice cream.
Ben and Jerry's had to get their own supplier to do the processing for us. They paid premium price but they paid market plus premium price. I got farmers to save half of the premium price toward getting their own facility and then so that they acquired that in 1997 and it's still operating women operating in now.
So I was telling this guy that he said you know when we were riding along in my car he said I have heard that story many many times but I heard that Rapunzel Page was the person who did that.
So a lot of my work got you know I'm just out here working trying to bring change not really trying to get the credit for what I did do and in many cases because I was working in organizations where the leadership was a male that work became known as theirs.
Any young women farmers? We are trying so hard now to actually there are few but that work that you see going on down there and some of the work in this room is geared toward bringing some women back into agriculture.
I would love it if we could just keep talking all the rest of the day and we know we need to wrap up so this has really been a great honor and a privilege thank you Mr. Rapunzel Page.
I really appreciate you sharing all this with us. Thank you.
From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.